how about this yeah I'm telling you no
one wears a suit like you oh yeah
you really don't wears orange like you
thank you James Bond
so you're here tonight for knives out
who'd a thunk that this movie would
really catch on grab us like it did and
just blow everybody away and well you
never you always you always hope of
course every time you make a movie you
hope that people get it but they really
did and I just I'm so happy that people
they get the gag I think we've all said
we haven't seen something this original
in the theaters in this long you know
well that's Ryan Johnson he's a bit of a
genius we're done with it's dying of a
diet
somebody's dying on some day and this is
some no time to die we're done yeah
we're gonna and how are you feeling I'm
feeling great yeah I'm very happy I'm
very proud of the five movies I've done
especially of this one it's gonna be
amazing so I'm very happy what do we
have to do to convince you that it's not
your last I'm I'm you know what it's
it's been an incredible ride and I I
couldn't be like I said could be proud
of what we've done with the movies and
it's time for somebody else do you have
someone in your mind that you'd like to
pass the torch just as long as they're
good yeah yeah the pageantry of this
night doesn't ever get old - you know
I'm this is not my comfort zone I mean I
can doesn't get old to me I never get
used to it I never quite understand it I
kind of just it's it's incredible but
it's I I can't I have to sort of pinch
myself it's like one of those situations
that it is this really happening okay
we'll take me into your life for a
second in if you're not here at the
Golden Globes on a Sunday what does
Daniel Craig doing on a Sunday as little
as possible like everybody else
you know with the family nice long
breakfast maybe some exercise in the
wall
yeah just just the normal stuff
[Music]